[Music]
I think it's an inevitability from about
halfway through the season that John and
Daenerys are gonna fall into bed
together and for us as actors it's just
weird the reality of what they are to
each other
I don't know how that's gonna I mean I
think I know might be the reaction I
like looking here and going oh god I'm
sorry
let's go yet I think they both know it's
wrong I think they both know it's gonna
cause problems but it's that thing when
you suddenly feel that deeply about
someone and you go through those events
together it's like a runaway train you
can't stop it happening father Smith
warrior to see that actually these were
two people in love and that this whole
thing that started off the series Game
of Thrones Robert's rebellion was a
total lie he's kind of like man and
what's gonna be interesting is for bran
it's like what am I gonna do with this
cuz just as everything was coming
together everyone was gonna join
together to fight inevitably Game of
Thrones will tear us apart
it's dangerous for everybody involved
I'm sure it's good for both of them in
the moment but you don't even get the
relief of how beautiful it could be or
should be it's no it's just it's not
good but it should be but it's not it's
Game of Thrones it's a long history of
romance not ending well on this show
you
you